Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two. David, P.
You know? Well, let me play the voicemail first.
It's about my conversations with Dave Rubin.
Let's play it first, and then I'll address it.
Speaker 7: Hey, David. I was just wondering if you
had an update or if you would have recently talked
to Dave Rubin, right? You know, he's somebody who
I think we all know what's happened with him,
but he's someone who initially I didn't really
pay much attention to. And then, you know, in 2016
17, 18, when he was doing the whole reform, the,
you know, reform the left anti progressive,
left kind of thing. I was like, Okay,
it's cool. Like, I don't agree with
everything he says, but it's cool,
right? Interviewed him around that time. Sure,
he was saying he's a classic liberal on all this,
but I think that we've just kind of seen his
evolution into something that is just completely,
you know, basically just Candace Owens. Like,
he's just he is. He's the guy that's who he is
at this point is like they're indistinguishable
from each other or like, you know, Charlie Kirk.
They're pretty much the same in terms
of what they say and what they believe.
Do you think there's anything genuine to Dave
Rubin's political awakening, if you want to call
it and have you maintained any kind of contact
with him? I'm just I'm just flabbergasted by him.
Speaker 1: And what's what's happened to him over
it? Yeah. So as many of you know, I used to be in
touch with Dave Rubin sort of regularly between
like exchanging emails and texts and sometimes
speaking on the phone. There's a long, long,
long time ago before his political awakening.
I believe that. Dave Reuben's political
awakening is completely sincere as far
as he is aware. Now I'm going to explain what
I mean by that. Most of the time when people
are I don't know how old he was when he maybe he
was 40 ish, when he had this complete political
realignment or awakening, as he calls it,
and left the left and is a Trump supporter
now. Most people at that age don't have that
unless one of two things has happened. One.
They never followed politics like they
were only so loosely following politics
that they kind of fell into whatever their
parents supported or friends or whatever
never really thought about it for the first time.
They learn about politics at age 40 and they go,
Oh, my politics are actually this. And so there
you might see a shift. That's not Dave Rubin
situation. He was in political media for years.
He was on Twitter and all this other stuff.
The second one is that you are bamboozled by
your own audience and financial opportunities
into believing that you actually believe
this stuff. So do I think Dave Rubin,
in his mind goes, I don't believe any of
this crap, but I'm making money from it. No,
I think Rubin has actually fallen for it. I think
he now is as far as he knows, a true believer. But
it's, of course, been influenced by the friends he
made in so doing and the money he made in so doing
now. I did. It recently exchanged some texts with
Dave Rubin. I don't know if you guys remember,
but not long ago I told the story of when I was
leaving a restaurant and someone yelled to me, Now
I don't. It was you jus Zionist pig. And I told
the story. And like, one or two little articles
were written about it, and somehow Rubin heard
about it and he texted me saying, You were now the
victim of the monster you helped create. And just
wait, what happens when people on the right come
out and start supporting you for what happened
to you? That never happened. Never happened. And
he was at least again as far as he was concerned.
He was completely genuine in what he was saying.
And so I do think that he is a true believer.
I do believe that he has fallen for it in some
total and it's very strange. And other than
that, I've not had any contact with Dave Rubin
in a really long time. That was probably. We
think it was kind of cold out. It must have
been early spring. It must have been like
when it was starting to get warm ish, like
maybe April of this year, something something
around that very, very strange stuff.
We've have we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today. As I mentioned earlier, the bonus show is
one of the many member benefits for signing up
on our website. Join passive income, sign up and
Unidentified: we'll see
you in mere moments on the.